hello america it's wednesday night in
nashville or as cat likes to call it no
officer those are not my drugs day
she's just holding them for a friend
a friend named keith richards oh yeah
what a great show what a great show
joining us tonight candace owens
candace has more haters on the left than
personal hygiene
that says something if she were any
smarter and beautiful she'd be me
oh and look who's joined us the charming
pete heg seth
you know he smiled and now the whole
front row is pregnant
[Laughter]
this guy has this guy has more brats
than the cars for kids commercial
he gives the ladies more hot flashes
than menopause
yeah like a hershey bar left in a hot
car when pete's when pete's on tv the
women just sit there and melt
not just the women pete
and of course we have cats
there she is
you know since she's been in nashville
she's really embracing the cowboy
lifestyle
[Laughter]
i give her points for trying
we had to put down the horse
and of course there's tyrus
i'll just move on
and we gotta thank the amazing audience
here tonight we love you
because you chose us
over all the other stuff like the crap
that's currently on late night tv and i
can't say i blame you have you seen
what's on colbert
no
[Music]
yeah it's a bunch of needles and one
annoying prick
too easy that was too easy
all right
that clip was from june but it's like
finding 20 bucks under a seat cushion it
may be old but it's new to us
who knew one of the side effects of the
jab was immediate cancer of the funny
bone
that was so bad it gave courtney love a
fear of needles
the audience probably wished those
needles were filled with cyanide it's
not an argument against vaccines it's an
argument for lethal injection
i fear you're gonna have to drink a
whole bottle of tequila to recover from
this or as cat calls it a juice cleanse
so i'm a nice person you are
speaking of vomiting
you know that's not the only thing
making us sick tonight the new york
times published redesigns of the
american flag because you know the
current one reeks of white privilege
look at this one
what the hell is this
i don't know whether to salute it or
calibrate the color on my new flat
screen
you know if your child showed you that
you kick the brat out of arts and crafts
if it were pete's kid he'd leave it by
the roadside on a family vacation
he's got plenty of spares what does he
care
now look at this one it's called lift
every voice and sing
i call it open every mouth and puke
do these people understand what a flag
is it's supposed to inspire patriotism
not an aneurysm
then there's this one
this one's giving me a migraine just
looking at it now my eyes know how my
ears feel when aoc speaks
seriously if you're gonna give me a
hangover at least let me earn it by
drinking that is not a flag it's the
wallpaper in a five dollar a night motel
in new jersey
not that i would know
that was quite a weekend though
it's a pattern for a clown's pajamas
and speaking of clowns and pajamas
so how's joe
doing know
according to an abc news poll public
approval of how he's handling key issues
is eroding faster than hunter's septum
i care about his health
by the way when this poll says key
issues they're talking about how long it
takes joe to find his keys every morning
but when it comes to polling he's more
underwater than a ted kennedy date
oh you feel bad about that well don't
don't kill anybody then
oh we offended somebody who let a girl
die my apologies
[Laughter]
but these his numbers are like joe's
teeth in a glass next to his bed
floating at the bottom
and he makes it worse by making crap up
that's positively hysterical colbert
should hire him as a writer did you hear
that the 3.5 trillion dollar spending
bill actually costs us nothing
yeah tell us joe
every time i hear this gonna cost a b c
or d
the truth is
based on the commitment that i made
it's going to cost nothing because we're
going to raise the revenue
sure you are gramps
and i'm going to start for the celtics
that next year not this year here's jen
some have expressed publicly that
they're not comfortable with uh 3.5 even
though zero cost zero dollars
yes some have disagreed publicly with
you and why because we aren't stupid and
we aren't suckers i mean what a total
street con this is see it's totally free
because we're gonna make the money
afterwards by taxing the hell out of you
but by the time we steal that money
we'll have another trillion dollar bill
which again we'll pay for later by
taxing the hell out of you it never ends
it's lather rinse and repeat or in joe's
case lather rinse and fall between the
sink and toilet
it's not a budget it's a pyramid scheme
one step from selling household cleaning
supplies from your trunk
so we elected biden instead we got
bernie madoff and apparently the
spending bill includes free community
college for illegal immigrants which
given the state of our education system
should be considered cruel and inhuman
punishment
by the time they graduate they won't be
qualified for anything but they'll have
learned 50 new pronouns for a bearded
lady
i just say bl
so what does joe have to say for himself
everybody's asking me joe
what's this gonna cost me what am i
gonna oh
i'm telling you stick with uncle joe
and you will owe nothing wait a minute
did he just say what i think he said
and i'm telling you stick with uncle joe
and you will own nothing
you will own nothing
now
nothing
that's what i thought he said
[Applause]
you know luckily for this white house
they can trust the media to back up the
bs this is an actual headline from the
washington post stop focusing on the
negative biden and harris have gotten
things done
yeah yeah you guys stop focusing on the
bad stuff okay
but that's like telling a death row
inmate that his last meal is gluten-free
but but hey maybe we should consider all
the good things the white house has done
let's go through that list
[Music]
that's so juvenile
by the way doing nothing isn't a bad
thing look how far it's gotten cat
but the thing is we're in a destruction
loop government creates a problem then
demands money to pay for it it's like
the guy that breaks 50 storefront
windows and then opens a glass company
the next day
that's our government which is why i
prefer a government that sits on its
hands because then its hands aren't
going through your wallet
or grabbing your ass
let's welcome tonight's guests
like sleeping on a water bed she's
always making waves conservative
commentator joseph candace on the daily
wire candice owens
back home in minnesota they call him the
original hot dish and he's two kids away
from a starting lineup there we go
boxing france weekend co-host pete
henson
the only thing neat about her is how she
drinks her whiskey fox news contributor
cat tim i'm nice
and when he rides the mechanical ball
the ball has to sign a waiver my massive
sidekick and the nwa's world television
champion tyrus
all right let's get to the show pete uh
he wrote a hero yeah
uh thank you for your service thank you
for yours oh i know don't do that you
don't have to
you have a lot of welcome you have a lot
of american flag tattoos are you going
to have to redesign your tattoos if they
change the flash that's an interesting
thought it is i've been thinking about
it all day a very simple exercise yes
looking at the color bars you put up on
the screen
i think about all those things you've
had dancing needle men yes you have
color bars right uh and then what was
the last example it was uh you can
everything 3.5 equals zero right and
it's they're all so cringe-worthy
they're cringe-worthy because
you want to laugh but the people saying
them are actually serious exactly that's
why it's so cringe-worthy it's like uh
you know cows farting are going to end
the planet right
that's how we not the islamists or the
marxists no no no no or
any other of the examples that you want
to provide when the left is so damn
serious about it but you but it looks
like a joke and it's why it rockets your
show to number one that's why it's so
cringy for every single everybody it's
like aoc is a serious thinker
the left thinks she is i just you just
made me think is why do cows fart so
much is it because they're lactose
intolerant
because
that's why i don't drink do cows eat
lactose i don't know they make it why
don't it's right there
if you can reach it
something i learned in grade school kids
so we celebrated three cringe word
worthy topics we had the flag redesign
colbert's musical theater joe biden not
doing math pick one that you find most
cringe words oh it's definitely gonna be
cobair like he just said something about
him he's just there's something maniacal
like i always [ __ ] just bubbling beneath
the surface like he's gonna have a
mental breakdown you know he's just
there's he makes me very nervous i never
feel comfortable when he's doing that
there's something about him that i'm
like he could wind up as a dateline
episode i just go bear cover i say that
don't do anything to me i have nothing
bad to say about you leave me alone uh a
cover but definitely him so cringeworthy
and you should never have to try that
hard to be funny yeah i mean like he
tries so hard and he misses the mark
every time see i don't try hard that's
why i miss the mark
but you know what the thing is what
you're talking about what is weird is a
background in musical theater right
think about everybody you know that was
somehow involved in musical theater
where are they now cat where are they
now they're probably living in your
apartment
i always had to be the narrator because
i can't sing yeah yeah oh i would love
to hear you sing you you wouldn't by the
way your dream is to be a dateline
episode no on forensic files i i don't
want to be murdered
i aim a little higher than that greg
uh but i want to talk about the flag
thing for a second sure i'm a little
confused about it honestly because i you
know read this article there's one of
the flags that had something on to
represent racism but i was confused
because flags as i understand them are
things you wave around to be like yay
this right so isn't it more offensive if
the flag is something bad like we don't
put bad things on flags there's no flag
that's like moderate to severe plaque
psoriasis we don't have that flag no we
don't we don't what is that
i i don't it's like picasso vomited
well well he probably did sometimes yes
well i would too if i was looking at
those paintings tyrus
what are your thoughts first of all
bulls don't ride bulls so let's just get
that out
i have no idea what he means
and
there was a time in my life when being
colorblind i was sad about it but i've
never been so happy to be colorblind
after what i saw
up there because i just saw a bunch of
grays and greens and i was like imagine
if i could see color i'd be throwing up
right now
the second thing is you guys are all
wrong they are telling the truth it will
cost you nothing because you will have
nothing you can't pay they're literally
trying to tax child support yeah
as if we don't get enough now you're
gonna taxes on that every time you give
your kids money to go to the store or
something taxing like they're going so
you literally won't be able to pay
anything because you have nothing so
they're telling you the truth they're
just not telling you the real truth but
then that's how it works in progressive
land where everything's fuzzy and warm
and nothing costs anything because we're
all in ninth place together and so you
can't pay your bills and we'll all live
in modular homes together so we'll all
kind of be rich when we're not killing
each other because there's no police
around to keep us from trying to kill
each other but yeah it's phenomenal it's
great yeah
all right we got to move on
by the way
you know i read the entire spending bill
yeah true yeah no i didn't i did you do
that i read a tweet okay i read a tweet
about it they're devoting three billion
dollars
to tree equity
tree equity because there's an
inequality of trees in this country so
we have to bring up the equality of
trees three billion dollars foliage
privilege what's the least equal tree i
don't know
all i know is it just means more places
to pee hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else